[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cloud
IDS detects malware,
spyware, command
and control attacks,
and other network-based threats.
Its security efficacy
is industry-leading,
built with Palo Alto
Network technology.
Being cloud native, Cloud
IDS is simple to deploy,
manage, and provides
high performance.
Customers can also use Cloud
IDS to support their compliance
goals.
This gives you the
ability to detect exploit
attempts, port scans,
buffer overflows, and more,
without having to manage
the infrastructure required
to host an advanced IDS.
All of this is automatically
integrated with cloud log-in,
allowing for alerts
in UI and the ability
to integrate your
SimSort platform in order
to take appropriate next
steps for your organization.
At a high level,
here's what happens.
First, we specify a Cloud IDS
endpoint to direct traffic
to VMs hosting the IDS system.
Then, in order to analyze
potential threats,
we set up a packet
mirroring policy
to duplicate and forward
packets into our IDS endpoint.
There's a lot of
flexibility around which
packets get mirrored, as users
can specify to forward packets
from one or more subnets,
instances with specific network
tags, or even select
instances by name.
The IDS VMs are then responsible
for analyzing and managing
the threats that
come into the system.
If threats are detected, they
are logged into Cloud Logging,
and we can, if we choose,
use Bitquery or other tools
to take automatic actions based
on the threats IDS discovered.
Getting started is
straightforward.
In the UI, within your VPC,
or Virtual Private Cloud,
navigate to the Network
Security Cloud IDS page
and create a new IDS endpoint.
We'll give it a name, select
a region for it to operate in,
and on the next page, we'll
select the threat levels
we want to be alerted for.
Once we select Create,
behind the scenes,
Google Cloud will set up
VMs to host the IDS system.
It will set up a load balancer
to manage traffic into it
and a bunch of other
useful infrastructure
to support securing
your platform.
Once that's finished, which
will take about 20 minutes
at the time of
this video, you'll
attach a new policy
to the endpoint
to define which package
you want to be mirrored.
In this case, we'll name
the policy, enable it,
and we'll specify
a subnet and we'll
mirror all packets from it.
This means that
any traffic coming
into or out of this range of
IP addresses will be duplicated
and forward over to the IDS
endpoint we set up previously.
To test this out, over
in the command line
we'll use Curl to send test
malware attacks to our server.
Back in our Cloud
IDS UI, you'll see
we now have a few threats
of various levels populated
in our UI.
By clicking on a threat,
I can see more information
about it, such as the source
and destination IP addresses,
and more.
Additionally, you can
click View All Threat
Logs, which will open up a
new tab with the threat logs.
At this point, we
could manually take
steps to fix some
of these threats,
or, just like with any
Cloud Logging logs,
we could use Bitquery or Pub/Sub
to forward these logs to a SIM
to perform additional
security response steps.
The last thing I want
to show before we go
is the Cloud IDS dashboard
that will show a high level
overview of your system,
including the top five
threats, source addresses,
and destination IP addresses.
You can click on any
of these dashboards
to get more information.
This is the power of
Cloud IDS in a nutshell.
It allows you to integrate the
functionality of Google Cloud
with Palo Alto
Network's advanced IDS,
giving you a managed
cloud scale security
system that just works.
For more information about
this and other security topics,
be sure to check out the
links in the description
for more information on securing
your cloud using Cloud IDS.
[MUSIC PLAYING]